[Música]
levanten la mano quienes creen en este
auditorio que tienen un don
listo gracias ahora levante la mano a
los que creen que tienen dos dones
ok ahora quiero ver quienes creen que
tienen más de dos dones
gracias bueno yo soy claudia isabel
cardona mejía nací en 1972 me gradué en
el colombo británico en 1990
este es el año 1976 mi papá y mi mamá
estábamos en el sur y en esa época
teníamos ocho citas de colores ya está
muy diferente el colegio
y en esa época pues por supuesto no
tenía ni idea que iba a pasar con mi
vida
pues llevo 46 años tratando de entender
quién soy por qué estoy aquí cuáles son
esos dones que me ha dado la vida y cuál
es mi misión y saben cuál ha sido mi
primer aprendizaje
que tengo el mismo don el mismo que el
mismo regalo que tenemos todos los que
estamos aquí presentes y es el don de la
vida la oportunidad de estar aquí
respirando para poder hacer para poder
actuar para poder vivir y ayudar a otros
y en ese proceso también descubrí que
hay un don que también tenemos todos los
que estamos aquí y que solamente por el
hecho de respirar y de estar vivos no
como cualquier ser viviente sino como
seres humanos es el don de liderar
y no estoy hablando así como dice el
autor robbins arma no estoy hablando de
liderar desde un gran cargo porque sí
por supuesto uno puede liderar desde un
cargo y es un ejercicio de liderazgo
puro pero cuando ese cargo te lo quitan
se pierde ese poder no yo estoy hablando
de un don real que nos da a todos un
poder natural
el poder natural del liderazgo
eso es un don que nadie te puede
arrebatar solamente nosotros decidimos
si hacemos uso de él o no hay que abrir
la gaveta porque él está allí
y en el momento que descubrimos ese don
hacemos conciencia de él
y entendemos el por qué hacemos cada
cosa que hacemos porque actuamos como
actuamos porque reaccionamos como
reaccionamos en ese momento la vida
cambia por completo todo toma un sentido
absoluto
y nos damos cuenta
qué es una gran oportunidad para
nosotros hacer un mundo mejor
allá arriba estoy una foto con mi
familia paterna realmente muy chiquitita
yo soy la que está aquí bonita en la
mitad tampoco tenía ni idea que iba a
hacer con mi vida todavía no sabía el
porqué de muchas cosas
mis papás eran quienes tomaban las
decisiones por mí todavía y era esta
foto - que tenía idea ahí sí que estaba
perdida pero pasando feliz realmente en
esos momentos de la vida lo que decidí
como ser humano fue abrazar las
oportunidades de compartir con mis
amigos de observar de escuchar y de
experimentar
y en ese ejercicio de observar de
escuchar de experimentar también me hice
muy consciente de otro don
que dios me dio que se llama el canto a
otras personas les dan otros dones
cierto hay personas que son muy hábiles
investigando creando
montando empresas liderando equipos
creando alimentos en fin pues a mí la
vida me dio el don de la voz aquí creo
que algunos me vieron en algún momento
otros no
pero digamos que en el camino de los
días tuve la oportunidad de irme un
retiro espiritual y ese día en ese
momento tuve un encuentro interior muy
muy profundo salieron algunas letras
cosas que yo nunca había hecho y todavía
no me considero una autora compositora
pero salieron cosas muy lindas
dentro de esas unas letras que tienen
que ver como con lo que les acabo de
compartir por qué
les digo somos piezas livianas al viento
solo formas de mil pensamientos somos
libres de escoger camino pero pocos lo
han conseguido somos seres de buenas
costumbres que en las sendas desviamos
apuntes somos rostros de paz subjetivo
sin saberlo lo hemos perdido quien
entienda esta hermosa creación que solo
se agobia sin razón cuando el horizonte
se oscurece pierde bay se desvanece
canta ya
[Música]
porque el tiempo se te acabará baila ya
goza ya porque luego no habrá marcha
atrás no confundas la euforia de un
momento fugaz reconoce la felicidad
y esta delación
empezaron los pares pero como no estás
cantando entonces yo hice caso y me abrí
a la oportunidad de cantar y mis papás
por supuesto me apoyaron mi cuñado todos
haciendo este emprendimiento me corté el
pelo porque la industria decía que ver
que pintarse el pelo es para lo que
estaba de moda porque esto que ven aquí
no se usaba me corté el pelo me pare el
pelo lo tuve todos los colores mi mamá
sufría por supuesto pero me dejaron ser
y experimenté y gracias a ese proceso
porque además además mi mamá tuvo mucho
que ver ella fue la que mismo porque no
vas a cantar a un bar de una amiga que
está buscando ahí conocí a el hombre de
mi vida
que también es músico
es mi compinche es mi amigo pasamos
delicioso y con el deco la tapa más
maravillosa
dice esta familia todos los estudiantes
del colombo
que también son también tienen
muchísimos dones y están aprendiendo a
liderar sus decisiones sus emociones y
demás
entonces en ese proceso me fui para
bogotá
me invitaron a hacer una novela en esa
novela hubo una escena que grabamos en
un bar de un gran artista que además
admiro muchísimo y miré en la vida mi
primer cd que compré se llamaba
poligamia la historia de mi generación
andrés cepeda y le dije que tengo el
baterista y entonces este es uno de los
jefes de mi marido o una de las personas
con las que trabajo gran amigo he
conocido grandes artistas
pero saben una cosa en el proceso de
vivir la música
y sentía que sé porque no estaba claro
realmente sentí que no estaba impactando
realmente la vida de los demás he
encontrado que la vida se vuelve
deliciosa cuando uno de verdad se dedica
a ayudar a otros a impactar la vida de
otros
entonces volví a estudiar y desde allí
mi carrera profesional que fue la
administración de empresas volvió a
tomar curso
y tú experiencias maravillosas en
diferentes empresas y luego gerencia un
centro comercial y luego me invitaron
aquí a gerenciar el valle del pacífico
de lo cual me siento muy orgullosa
porque sé que estamos haciendo con el
equipo una gran labor por nuestra región
y gracias a eso conocí alejo
buenaventura que es un gran actor en
teatro pero además trabaja aquí en
delirio a andrea que lidera otro gran
proyecto y así personas maravillosas
directores de grandes compañías
y esto todos los días me ha hecho crecer
y pensar que tenemos todos muchísimo por
liderar no estoy hablando de un cargo de
liderar somos seres en mi latitudes que
en la senda buscamos la cumbre somos
gente de amor somos tierra pero basta
por dios de esta guerra quien entiende a
esta hermosa creación que solo se agobia
sin razón cuando el horizonte se
oscurece pierde fey se desvanece canta
ya
y ella porque el tiempo se te acabará
baila ya todos allá porque luego no
habrá marcha atrás no confundas la
euforia de un momento fugaz reconocen la
felicidad
la felicidad como se le aprendiz al
líder que más me gusta que se llama
jesús que es un paz y gozo permanente
porque la euforia es un momento de mucha
emoción y nos puede hacer equivocarnos
en cambio la felicidad verdadera es paz
y gozo permanente si aprendemos a hacer
conciencia del por qué hacemos cada cosa
la vida es un viaje delicioso
y saben una cosa hoy es triste que en el
mundo
se admira más a la gente que es popular
que a la gente que es valiente y que es
buena
así que yo quiero alzar la mano antes de
terminar y compartirles el resultado de
ese ejercicio de composición cómo quedó
que alcen la mano los que creen que
tienen muchos dones y que son capaces de
hacer conciencia de liderarlos y de
hacer de este mundo un mundo mejor que
levanten la mano
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
asuncion estas presentaciones
[Música]
somos fiestas guiadas al viento sólo
formas de mil pensamientos somos libres
de escoger camino pero pocos lo han
conseguido
somos seres de buenas costumbres en las
células del amor
los rostros de paso el tipo sabe no lo
hemos perdido
ah
la creación
eso lo agobia
pero son oscuras
el amanecer pantalla
porque el tiempo se le abrió
bailar
y luego no
no confundas
la euforia de un momento no reconoce los
felices
[Aplausos]
[Música]
desde mi latitudes que la senda buscamos
la portería como gente mejor sociedad
pero gasta por dios de estar él
tienen que estar moza creación
que sólo se apoya sin razón como el
horizonte se oscurece pierde el que vale
están talladas
y
porque siento se te haga nada
bailar
batallas porque luego dura
no confundas euforia de amor
343 en la feliz
pantalla
familiar
el tiempo se te haya parado
bailar
para fallar
de juego ahora marcha atrás
soria de un momento fugaz reconoce la
feliz
[Música]
y tal
[Aplausos]